su médico puede recomendarle que reciba
una transfusión de sangre para tratar su
afección médica o para salvar su vida su
sangre transporta oxígeno y nutrientes a
todos sus tejidos y retira el dióxido de
carbono y otros productos de desecho de
estos la sangre también ayuda a combatir
la infección y a cicatrizar las heridas
la sangre está formada por una porción
de líquido y componentes celulares el
líquido llamado plasma es en donde los
nutrientes hormonas factores de
coagulación y otros químicos se
disuelven los componentes celulares en
vez de disolverse se suspenden en el
plasma están formados por glóbulos rojos
que transportan el oxígeno y el dióxido
de carbono
glóbulos blancos que combaten la
infección
y plaquetas que son sus células pequeñas
que ayudan a la sangre a coagularse
las células sanguíneas se producen en la
médula ósea un tejido suave que se
encuentra dentro de varios de sus huesos
una transfusión de sangre utiliza sangre
donada para reabastecer de glóbulos
rojos glóbulos blancos plaquetas
factores de coagulación plasma o sangre
completa entre las circunstancias que
pueden requerir de una transfusión de
sangre se encuentran pérdida de sangre
como consecuencia de traumatismo cirugía
del corazón u otra cirugía mayor
trasplante de órganos trastornos
hemorrágicos como hemofilia anemia
severa incluyendo anemia de células
falciformes tratamiento para la leucemia
u otro tipo de cáncer trastornos que
destruyen las células sanguíneas o la
médula ósea o incompatibilidad rh en
recién nacidos
para iniciar la transfusión se insertará
una aguja intravenosa en la vena de su
mano o brazo
se colgará cerca una bolsa que contiene
la sangre donada y la sangre gotear a
lentamente a través de un tubo anexado a
la aguja intravenosa permitiendo que
corra por su vena hacia su torrente
sanguíneo durante toda la transfusión se
controlará su temperatura frecuencia
cardíaca respiración y presión arterial
luego que la bolsa esté vacía se
colocará otra bolsa en el tubo
intravenoso en caso necesite más sangre
cuando la transfusión finalice se
retirará la aguja
luego de la transfusión su médico
controlará sus signos vitales para
asegurarse de que no tenga una reacción
adversa si es necesario posiblemente se
le administre un diurético para reducir
cualquier hinchazón o retención de
líquido